hi I'm Doug Walker from channel awesome
at the end of our most popular show
nostalgia critic we always do a charity
shout out encouraging people to donate
well they've done well we realize not
everybody's in a financial situation
where they can give but everybody at
some point or another can give time so
every month we're gonna try and show a
new charity or organization that you can
help out with there's so many people in
difficult circumstances but thankfully
there's always people who are willing to
help and you can be one of them whether
it's volunteering or lending a helping
hand we're here to show you what you can
do
[Music]
I'm David Diaz I'm the development
manager for save a pet which is a
no-kill Animal Rescue and adoption
center in Grayslake Illinois we've been
in existence since 1972 so were 46 years
old and we started in Palatine and then
in 1995 we moved here to our facility in
Grayslake
in what way does save a pet save a pet
well in 46 years we've served about 63
thousand animals we serve about a
thousand animals on average a year we
deal with only cats and dogs we are a
true and pure no-kill mission here at
save abet so we don't turn any animals
away based on temperament or behavior
age their history their medical needs
anything like that we are totally
inclusive of all animals and we do
whatever it takes to set them on the
road to recovery and adoption they
always say it's better to adopt rescue
sure everyone says that you know but
yeah but but in your opinion that why is
that just so incredibly oh well it's so
incredibly important because there are
so many animals that need to be adopted
there are animals waiting to become part
of your family and enrich your lives and
instead of going out and supporting
someone who is breeding more and more
animals our philosophy is that it makes
more sense for people to come adopt
animals that are here already in Mena
home animals are very forgiving and
they're very resilient and most of them
have an open heart to new experiences
and so when they feel that they have
become part of that family
they'll act in kind
that and so we have animals that have
been bait dogs for fighting dogs we have
animals that have been in direct abuse
situations or domestic abuse situations
and things like that we all go through
life right and the life has different
things that it throws at you like you
lose your job and you need to move to an
apartment you might not be able to
include your animal and so they'll bring
their animal here and they'll relinquish
the animals so they've all these animals
have had different unique experiences
they are able to make the adjustments to
become you know part of that family in a
really really great way top off so far
what information is there that you feel
people don't know enough about that they
should about adopting a pet getting a
rescue anything like that they make
wonderful family pets and I think that
some people are a bit standoffish of
that they're just like any other dog
whether you adopt or or you purchased
the dog you know they'll still find
their role within the family it's no
different it's just that these dogs have
an immediate need to find a family some
shelters and rescues the adoption
process is super easy peasy and they
don't take a lot of things into
consideration but we're really
interested in having a successful
long-term adoption for that Hanul if you
are renting you should have your lease
with you stating that you can have an
animal we ask that at some point during
the process everybody who lives in the
home comes into say the patent has an
interaction with the animal it is part
of it because there's no rush because
there's not a fear that you know the
animal is gonna be put down or anything
like that that you can take your time
and really get the right animal for the
right person yeah I mean that's part of
it we're in no rush we don't take
waiting lists and we don't hold animals
for people it's a first-come serve
situation that being said
you know we're just trying to have the
most successful experience for the
animal I don't want to sound trite but
people are secondary to us in this
process it's really all about the animal
this is kind of special to us this is
called our Tree of Life and this is
where some of our major donors decide to
buy a leaf and they add their name to be
recognized as a major supporter of same
path this is not government funded no a
lot of it comes from donations and
people giving funds and stuff like that
what is the major difference between a
place that maybe has government funded I
mean to be general about it the
expectations and the regulation of the
operations and processes are totally
different if we were to take
governmental funds they would have an
input and on our mission which is a pure
no-kill mission and we've just refused
to waver from that we get it done
through individual donors and business
partners who help us out with sponsoring
different events and things like that
here's four or five different save the
pets throughout the world but we serve
Lake County and they're not affiliated
with each other but they're all doing
you know animal welfare work based on
the name I guess why would you be the
same appellant yes I make myself lotta
bottles or something and every once in a
while we'll get a donation for maybe as
the same a pet that's in Florida or
something like that and then we need to
call the donor and I'm always amazed at
people's generosity because they say you
go out and keep that and I'll just send
another cheque to the save a pet the
Florida which is is wonderful for you
what is the best part of doing this one
the Development Manager so I have a big
passion in helping people find helping
out what they're passionate about
it's like brokering a deal almost right
you've got a donor here who wants to
help out and wants to learn what they
can do that will actually make a
difference right and then we've got
administration and leadership who needs
to have cost covered if we're going to
put in a new parking lot we need a new
fence so I really enjoy getting those
two people in the same room and figuring
it out with each other
aside from that seeing all the you know
cute little animals around it there's
always a bonus I have a lot of animals
at home they're all rescuing animals
although I've adopted two animals from
save a pet I'm taking a break right now
that's a well what is your favorite that
oh I'm a dog person I personally like
Australian Shepherds just because of
their personality and their energy and
they just want to work but I find myself
as I'm getting a little bit older I
never thought I'd like little dogs and
now like little Jack Russell terriers
and stuff I really think they're I'm
still trying to get on that boat ooh man
I see a little dog I'm like you're not a
dog but I'm like I know you are but it's
like I know people have had little dogs
and they say the same thing like I hated
them at first but man we get to know
them they're just a wonderful animal and
I I got to figure that out to each their
own there's some people who like
Mastiffs and st. Bernard's and these big
dogs and there's some people who can't
imagine having that on their couch would
they want just a little pee candies or
something you know like that what's
great here and say that that is that
we've got all kinds of dogs or a cat for
everybody here you just need to come in
and make that connection if I know which
one is for you what's one of the more
either amazing or inspiring like pet
stories that that's come through here
they use oh my gosh there's so many like
we see something every month that just
kind of as a jaw-dropper Willie Nelson
is a cat that came in that suffered an
accident out on the road it got hit by a
car and somebody found it in a ditch and
brought it to us three of its four legs
were fleece basically the fur and skin
was missing on three of the lakes most
every other animal rescue shelter would
find themselves in a position where they
would
the choice I think to euthanize that
animal then we don't and so we spent a
lot of money on Willie Nelson went
through recovery and is with a family
today and you would have no idea that
Willie had that experience at all so
like all the furs back on his leg so
every bad just like that is crazy
totally crazy he just looks like a
normal cat a normal cat bopping around
and you know he would jump up on the
counter and you'd be like nice cat you
just would have no idea but they're like
I said very resilient and you know they
just adapt and overcome this show it's
very much based on you know volunteering
and how people can help and stuff like
that what are some things people
watching at home if they wanted to give
some time to save a pet in any way what
can they do well first what they would
need to do is go through the orientation
process and the training which is very
simple and fast and then there's a whole
myriad of things people can do they can
come in and simply help clean the cat
rooms in the morning they can come in
and walk dogs they could bathe dogs we
have an agility course out back they
could teach agility to different dogs we
run a lot of off-site community outreach
and fundraising events so we're always
looking for people to help take dogs and
cats off-site to different events that
are happening volunteer for fundraising
committees to help us raise money and
they can bring their friends and family
and turn them into volunteers and say
that that's borders as well some people
would just donate like a birdfeeder is
somebody it's like hey I want to donate
like to save a bad I mean is that
something they can do they can kind of
take to you yeah absolutely
yeah you can find my information on the
website but you can email me or call me
or just call the front desk and we can
figure all of that out but literally on
a daily basis I talked to people who if
maybe had a dog pass and they bring in
all of his stuff which is really a sad
one and then we've got somebody who just
had the day off and they decide they're
gonna go to a store and buy 100 bucks
worth of stuff and bring it to save
about that's good yeah it's very cool
and we don't we can't do it without
people like that so whether people want
to volunteer donate give time give money
whatever they want you to do my way you
look right at that camera and tell them
what website they can go to what place
they can go to need to go to www.hsn
because these animals are counting on
you thank you and they are adorable
these are keeping animals that's
yourself you made things done thanks for
coming out today thank you thank you for
having us yeah
[Music]
you